in the show it starts with your mom
passing away and your character speaks
with your mom even though she's passed
away a lot interact with her a lot I
know that your mom has passed is that
something that you really do do I
actually interact with my mother yeah I
don't think so
right my wife thinks my mother interacts
with me like 2:00 in the morning the
song Penny Lane started playing in our
house and and we just I kept talking to
my wife and she said are you not going
to acknowledge that Penny Lane is
playing through our house at 2:00 in the
morning and I I said okay well there's
an electronic malfunction I guess
because what was it was your stereo
system had gone on or something yeah The
Beatles were there well I guess I'm the
how do they do they beep
on this show I don't know you don't you
don't watch it I feel like I'm still
drinking that whiskey drink I it's right
here I feel like they always beep hole
on like that you can chance what
are they beep yeah oh why did it why did
you know that so quickly you were right
there with my coal but why don't they be
bad yeah why not blank hole anyway oh so
you don't know nope
I like that you dig this deep under the
surface like I don't know I don't watch
this I don't watch this show either I
know for sure they'd be poll ok yeah
makes no sense
okay that's what I came on to promote so
anyway this music comes on the other
night yeah and and and what's your
girlfriend say well she's my wife Conan
I mean your wife
this guy huh he just he doesn't believe
that he's married so he doesn't think
anyone can pay yeah
I've been married 14 years I call my
wife my girlfriend I think it keeps the
sex life alive does it nope
[Applause]
penny and I are touring the country with
this act you're gonna love it
I can't live off of that you have to
babysit as well I know we get a lot of
electronic malfunctions around the house
that's all it is she's saying oh this is
like a what a message from your mom yeah
but the Beatles Penny Lane is playing in
the house yeah I'm in your camp
I'm whenever something like that happens
I know people who would be like oh
that's someone from another world
communicating a mic no electronic glitch
yeah she she doesn't believe that at all
but in the show there are no electronic
malfunctions I'm just talking to and
running into and my mother and having
flashbacks and it's a comedy but there's
also very dramatic moments to it okay
but no no no Penny Lane playing or write
anything like that
you